[Music]
in mother science news that's my
favorite subject submitted by bean and
cheese oh that's a bomb that's what I
call you to my head
who is it cheese now you got to figure
that out for yourself Oh me and Bart
we're being Jesus bark as he farts
cheese yeah didn't Jesus she does not
you me I'm kind of Jesus scientists now
believe people consume live beyond 120
years I'm going to prove that wrong
that's tight I'm going to die without
science the radioactive Japanese
grandparents they they stay alive like
long live longer
pretty soon Joe Joey subtitles I know
how I think I mean them now no like
without science you know like in Okinawa
they have all those radioactive Japanese
grandparents theory or like radioactive
grandparents in Japan like the Harris
Jayma ones they live like like a
thousand years like they're like these
old weight naturally or cuz of
radioactive now I just say that because
they have radioactivity but I think it's
natural they equate it to eating a very
huge amount of bitter melon man oh
people always making [ __ ] up they never
say it's their genetics and their
healthy lifestyle they say you know why
I live so late it's because I eat
[ __ ] goat dick every morning then how
do you know that ha ha I don't know
because all these people that live long
they have their different reasons like
there was as longest-living
veteran in Texas as this guy that's like
a hundred and seven years old
smokes a cigar drinks [ __ ] whiskey
every night or whatever he attributed it
to his freedom
he's like Okawa ice cream I'm ie a
sprain it's just genetics dude he just
had great genes yeah I think happiness
keeps you alive for a very long time
yeah can you tell me about how people
who live past a hundred say that to my
grandmother that [ __ ] is grumpy but
she's still alive and she's like 98 it's
the bitter melon is
I'm really talking about how we're going
to live longer is just a researchers
from the Albert Einstein College of
Medicine in New York they suggested that
the human lifespan has like a cutoff
there's no way humans can live past 125
years but the Bible says otherwise
oh yeah they said they were living for
like five hundred five hundred years I
should I should only part of the Bible
living that's because their math was all
yeah but now there's this new study
that's a [ __ ] up birthday cake there's
no cake left on it you need a cake this
exhibition you're jacking off little
dick and 600 candles can you believe
that [ __ ]
are you into fine - three candles six
zero zero now you gotta go legit what
they add a candle no kabedon you know
they use wood they use Roman numerals
right I don't think they celebrated
birthdays back in the day they did the
[ __ ] xxxxX 1 1 1 1 X X 1 X 1 - that
[ __ ] cake is not going to exist this
is a bunch of crumbs and cream
everywhere you think they ain't cakes in
the Jesus days maybe I think I think
what they had was bread routers in the
projects put candles on fish when I see
those medieval drawings man it's sad
dude they always got like a plate of
[ __ ] dead birds and like a fish and
some fruits and vegetables and like a
loaf of bread that looks hard as [ __ ]
bricks it's like what they would do I
mean it's so healthy like they don't go
they don't know the joys of McDonald's
it's good like the regular people would
eat that [ __ ] and the royalty would eat
you know big [ __ ] feast while regular
people are just eating jerky and bread
all day
but the dehydrated ships on the new ass
yeah so there is a new study by McGill
University from Quebec Canada they're
arguing that there is no evidence is
like a maximum lifespan humans can reach
and so they believe or this study
they're just saying that you know humans
can live who knows how long scientists
they just sit around a [ __ ] [ __ ] and
argue all day long they need to find
something better to do know
that's why they get no [ __ ] they're
getting decisis cookie yeah there's no
movers or calculators and [ __ ] but know
the circumference of the world is not
3.8 it's this one and then they're just
fighting from school to school and [ __ ]
it's like you guys but they're like gang
yeah but you know they really doing
nothing but just talking about imaginary
possum [ __ ] movie [ __ ] though all right
maybe one day prove it right in the
clock all right
make three fun alright maybe they're
cool they're super cool do you think
you'd get more or less [ __ ] if you
announced like - girl you're hitting on
that you go to the [ __ ] Albert
Einstein with a college of [ __ ]
genius if it was on the girl I think why
what are they going to get for you you
act like you try to find future husband
going to the engineering department in
the school you don't no no no Tom Hanks
I'm saying outside of the school so now
we're not even at your classmate let's
just use you for an example all right I
would be impressed I don't want to [ __ ]
them exactly that's what I was adding
y'all exactly that's what there are
people that work for them no yet you see
you have mixers like that like our one
of our friends Brian he grows
specifically to these mixers to meet Ivy
League women they want they want to [ __ ]
them they want their day they're trying
to [ __ ] each other in that class you
find you're not they're not looking for
nerds - [ __ ] you telling me you going to
Comic Con to get some dick a lot of
comic money and Stu I mean some people
are very choice yeah stand up to that
[ __ ] Juliet he'll take some people I
agree
yes some people I agree yeah but is that
your cream of the crop men that you look
for hey you know what there's a lot of
ha men that really geek out at all I
don't and I don't I don't I'm not
denying I get dweeb shut up
all I'm saying I'm [ __ ] kidding I
love Connor Kasich you're just jealous
have you been with the comic-con three
years in a row [ __ ] loser
all I'm saying is they're so busy
working on this that they're not getting
this Santa says the guy would [ __ ] him
back to the future on it ha ha ha ha hi
Gina Hey from a nerd to the nerds out
there from this one nerd you don't get
anything
no from one note to another owner
[ __ ] [ __ ] to another that's on
saying I gotta let you guys know is
don't argue with the girl about [ __ ]
sky and [ __ ] and get [ __ ] mad cuz you
ain't going to god there you go don't
get butthurt if her theory does not
match your theory ok
yeah so going back on this whole
lifespan thing though so they're saying
back in 1841 the average lifespan of a
person was about 40 years make sense
smallpox and then now I was brought by
the [ __ ] ethnic people just couldn't
you know why though this is what people
think average lifespan is 40 years right
what they think is at 40 40 years old
people died but that's not the case
average lifespan of society equals how
many people are dying at what age a lot
of infant mortality and you people died
when they're very little that's why
people had a ton of [ __ ] kids
people did survive past the age of 60
all that [ __ ] but they just have to make
it past like 12 or adolescents so that's
why that statistic is actually wrong
people were living longer
it's just now with antibiotics people
are living even more longer babies are
surviving so that's the average age
isn't people aren't dying at court now
an honorary to [ __ ] the popular
underneath to be a Spartan politician
you had to be 60 years old so what does
that tell you [ __ ]
isn't that why Koreans celebrate the
first year the baby's life is like a
hundred and so we celebrate 100 day
because that oh [ __ ] you survived and
you're not going to [ __ ] die and I
want to pop out another one yep what are
you saying again I'm still just an
article oh you are thank you party
so they're just saying now that like a
baby born in 2011 can expect to live
seventy-nine years and we could do I'm
sorry I don't worry me dazzle the forty
years and what what what you can 41:18
is that in America because I don't think
that's in America because most Americans
would like me another thing a British
person born in exactly
yeah but they got had corroded teeth
like that bikini I just say look in
Britain the food is bad so of course in
the live long they cook in their Chinese
a lot more simple in are sufficient
ships and in Shepherd pies and beer and
beer that tastes survive of beer and
french fries that's right right who is
so Bob yes scientists are just arguing
that with technology and medical
interventions and improvements on the
way of living like we can expect that
the average human life span will be
extended you know what to be honest with
you if I'm all the family nine years old
I don't want to be shark I want to be
dumbest fun why because I want to live
in a fantasy world until that age but
what if it's a nightmare
I don't want to be like because my
grandpa raffle was so excited to see me
every day he looks so happy though good
so he was like a magic trick
and then he'd walk away like who the
[ __ ] is that guy I know but he doesn't
know that's not the reality for him
that's reality for us but he looked
happy as hell I would make him [ __ ]
ramen because he loved that [ __ ] he
would eat like this all gone so cold I
just don't want to lose my working limbs
so imagine you're old right but like
what's the point of survival that's what
I'm saying I'd rather just be insane
yeah it's like I'd rather just die and
come back [ __ ] reset button that
[ __ ] you know what's the point
from 90 to 120 what's the point does you
want to have sex at that age if my dick
works hell yeah hey guys would you think
of that video I know you loved it so
make sure to hit that like button to
watch more videos check out up here
[Music]